der Herr Bundespräsident hat mir mit
Schreiben vom heutigen Tage mitgeteilt
gemäß Artikel 63 Absatz 2 des
Grundgesetzes für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
habe ich heute Herrn Abgeordneten Olaf
Scholz zum Bundeskanzler ändern
nach Artikel 64 Absatz 2 des
Grundgesetzes
leistet der Bundeskanzler bei der
Amtsübernahme vor dem Deutschen
Bundestag den in Artikel 56 des
Grundgesetzes vorgesehenen als Herr
Bundeskanzler ich bitte Sie zu
Eidesleistung zu mir zu kommen
Herr Bundeskanzler ich halte die
Urschrift des Grundgesetzes in meinen
Händen ich bitte Sie die in Artikel 56
vorgeschriebene Eidesformel zu sprechen
ich schwöre dass ich meine Kraft dem
Wohle des deutschen Volkes wird bin
seinen Nutzen mehren Schaden von ihm
wenden das Grundgesetz und die Gesetze
des Bundes wahren und verteidigen meine
Pflichten gewissenhaft erfüllen und
Gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde
vielen Dank ich danke Ihnen viel Glück
für ihre Aufgabe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stelle fest